how do you think artificial intelligence
uh is going to change the rap game
because you know you I'm sure you've
seen a lot of these crazy uh
like fake songs from artists yeah I mean
I just feel like you know I don't know
we gotta we got it's still new so we
gotta wait and see like I want somebody
to take someone random like Adele and
make an AI version of Adele doing crank
that that's all right let's do it
someone's gonna do that out there
because they're going to see this yeah
somebody's gonna like it's possibly the
possibilities is endless man you can do
so much stuff but it's at the end of the
day it could be a good thing it could be
a bad thing you just gotta wait and see
how do you think it could be bad
how can anything be bad even get out of
control you know what I'm saying hi
robot scoring Will Smith you know people
use it in the wrong way you know what
I'm saying well you know do you have a
are you like pretty hip to the uh like
you know just the AI [__] in general you
have you have you [__] around on chat
gbt yet yeah I've been I'm in you know
on through all the AIS you dig what I'm
saying chat GPT all that you know what
did you what did you converse with chat
gbt about because I actually know
artists who have asked
chat GPT what they should do for their
album rollout yeah and like it'll write
like a 10 paragraph like album roll out
now I know no it's funny like
the [__] that I I typed in a couple
things but the [__] that I typed in it
was like oh I can't help you with that
sir that's it's all typing in some
others I was trying to figure out what
what okay okay where's the G-spot just
know that they have no answer for me
they said I can't help you with this sir
I said now close the app out they said
this is this this is you know we can't
we can't help you with this do you have
a electric car yet like an EV Tesla or
anything I'm gonna come out with my own
car so how's your car really come on my
own car How's that gonna have like is
this already is this something that's
real or are you just saying it sometimes
I feel like you just be saying [__] I
mean just it is it this ain't this is
this idea that I have okay said that
right now okay it ain't that an official
but you want to do a soldier card hey
come on man tell my electric car I was
like come on man but I like to Tesla
little got the big TV screen you have a
Tesla I got no Tesla man I like I gotta
I like like Hellcat it's like I got the
Hellcat like I want to go fast I want to
I want to hear it you know but I like it
though it looked good right and you know
stuff like that it was just kind of slow
but did you see the Tesla slow oh Miss
slow which what
do you know that the test was the
fastest car that anybody can buy in the
United States then a Lamborghini yeah
it'll smoke the Tesla Model S plaid will
smoke we're not talking about Tesla
Model flat we just want the regular
Tesla just I'm telling you they're
smoking on Lamborghini man what okay
listen the Tesla Model S plaid watch
this 140
000 West is not Model S play at all
Tesla models can smoke a Lamborghini
that's what you told I would say half of
them okay cool fix it half a model X and
a Model S well not all alone come on man
you're not telling me I might roll in
the wrong Tesla though you know what I'm
saying it was DJ Vlad Tesla I don't know
that [__] was slow it might have been
the right wait first of all you're
hanging out with vladica it was a long
time ago it was a long time ago that's
about to say before even having to touch
that [__] was slow as [__] I was like I
was like what the [__] I gotta go for
Atlanta what was the car ride like with
you and DJ Vlad and the Tesla he's like
look Soldier the car you could drive
itself oh I'm like man watch out with
this [__]
when are you gonna make your triumphal
return to Vlad I
said I don't know you know I'm gonna
pull up on them are you guys good now
hell no
I'm pull up on them though we gonna talk
though you know I'm saying get a little
interview done I feel like it's it's
like
it also could be very
um
I feel like he'd probably throw you a
bag every three weeks to do an interview
like he does with boozy he I don't want
his money man yeah everything ain't
about the money sometimes just like
respect principles [__] like yeah morals
you know what I'm saying I got three
Styles bro I can make money yeah I could
walk out of here and make however much
money I want right now you know I
appreciate that everybody
to talk to you like
you like artists
they're approach
that's why I [__] with you bro not for
sure what would you do